rejoignez-moi sur patreon pour accéder à
l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des courants visaux
des apérophilos un moyen simple de
soutenir mon travail tout en vous
donnant matière à penser je vous attends
sur patreon le lien est dans la
description bonjour à
tous aujourd'hui on va parler de
Nietzsche et de la
médisance Nietzsche est un philosophe
dont on a déjà parlé à plusieurs
reprises sur cette chaîne c'est un
philosophe qui a eu une grande influence
sur la pensée européenne et dont
certains d'ailleurs se réclament encore
aujourd'hui mais Nietzsche est aussi un
philosophe qui diviseent qui cLIV il
Clive non seulement les nietzséens et
les antiichzéens mais bon ça on pouvait
s'y attendre mais il CVE aussi les
nietzsiens eux-mêmes c'est-à-dire que
parmi les gens qui se réclament de
Nietzsche on trouve des personnalités on
trouve des profils idéologiques
totalement en antagonistes des
nietzséens de gauche et des nietzséens
de droite des nietzséens libertaires et
des nietzsens
traditionnalistes ça paraît étrange et
pourtant c'est le cas et d'où est-ce que
ça vient ça vient essentiellement du
fait que la pensée de Nietzsche n'est
pas une pensée de système et que donc on
peut l'adapter à des idéologies très
différentes une pensée de système c'est
quand un philosophe construit une vision
du monde cohérente et
unifiée c'est quand la pensée se déploie
selon un enchaînement logique et
structuré et que donc quel que soit le
morceau de raisonnement que vous allez
prendre dans ces textes ce morceau de
raisonnement peut être mis en relation
avec un autre morceau de raisonnement or
chez Nietzsche ça marche pas comme ça
chez Nietzsche la pensée est beaucoup
plus
fulgurante beaucoup plus
fragmentaire quand on lit nietzs on lit
quelqu'un qui à tout moment peut dire
quelque chose à quoi on ne s'attendait
pas voir quelque chose qui semble
contradictoire avec ce qu'il a dit juste
avant pour en revenir à ce que je disais
Nietzsche n'est pas un auteur classable
en terme
d'idéologie c'est pour ça que vouloir
concilier Nietzsche avec un engagement
politique c'est forcément un peu
compliqué pendant longtemps Nietzsche a
été une figure très en vogue à gauche
chez foucco chez DELEUSE et même encore
aujourd'hui chez quelqu'un comme
François béodo alors même que niet che
quelqu'un qui a écrit je cite le
socialisme est le frère Cadé du
despotisme c'est quelqu'un qui a écrit
qui est-ce que je ai le plus parmi la
racaille d'aujourd'hui la racaille
socialiste qui rend l'ouvrier envieux
qui lui enseigne la vengeance et il
ajoute l'injustice n'est jamais dans
l'inégalité des droits mais dans la
revendication de droits
égaux difficile d'être de gauche et
d'écouter ça sans
sourciller est-ce que ça veut dire que
Nietzsche était un philosophe de droite
non parce que Nietzsche c'est aussi
quelqu'un qui a écrit je cite la maladie
fait partie de l'essence du
christianisme c'est quelqu'un qui a
écrit le nationalisme cette névrose
nationale dont le europeope est
malade donc vous voyez que c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué dès qu'on veut
faire rentrer Nietzsche dans des
catégories binaire parce que Nietzsche
n'est pas un penseur binaire c'est un
penseur subtil et comme tout penseur
subtile il n'a pas peur de sortir des
lignes de malmener l'éclivage et c'est
ce qui en fait un philosophe aussi
passionnant et en même temps aussi
clivant maintenant si on parle de ce que
signifie être NCH un il y a quand même
un critère un critère
objectif ce critère c'est la volonté de
puissance Nietzsche promeut la volonté
de puissance et qu'est-ce que c'est la
volonté de puissance c'est l'exaltation
de la vie l'exaltation de la vie sous
toutes ses formes j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de parler de la volonté de
puissance dans mes précédents épisodes
sur Nietzsche je vous y renvoie ici on
va aller assez vite mais pour que vous
ne soyez pas totalement perdu ce que
vous devez retenir c'est que la volonté
de puissance se manifeste de différentes
manières et l'une de ces manières c'est
l'indifférence aux valeurs morale
traditionnel au bien et au mal à la
vertu et au vice pour Nietzsche les
valeurs morales traditionnelles sont de
fausses valeurs des valeurs qui ne
trouvent pas leur fondement dans la
nature des valeurs qui ne viennent pas
non plus de Dieu ou du ciel des idées ce
sont des inventions humaines et plus
précisément des inventions des faibles
des inventions des faibles pour se
protéger des forts en inventant la
morale ce que nietzs appelle la morale
d'esclave les faibles ont trouvé le
moyen de neutraliser
leseff la morale c'est ce qui interdit
au
de maltraiter le faible c'est ce qui met
le fort et le faible sur un pied
d'égalité et donc c'est ce qui permet de
dire au fort tu ne va pas mieux que nous
ta force ne te rend pas
supérieure nous sommes
supérieurs car nous avons la justice de
notre côté
or ça nous dit Nietzsche c'est un
mensonge c'est un mensonge parce que la
motivation réelle de ceux qui ont
inventé la morale ce n'était pas d'être
juste c'était de se
venger de se venger
d'effort de soumettre l'effort à des
lois et à des règles qui les empêchent
d'exprimer leur volonté de
puissance autrement dit pour Nietzsche
la morale n'est pas le produit de la
justice elle n'est pas le produit de
l'amour du prochain
elle est le produit de la haine elle est
le produit du ressentiment du
ressentiment des faibles contre les
forts travesti en amour du prochain et
en idéal de
justice c'est ça l'acte fondateur de la
morale d'esclave le
ressentiment et c'est là qu'on en arrive
à la question qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui à savoir la médisance car
pour Nietzsche la médisance est une des
manifestations elle est même la
manifestation la plus pure du
ressentiment
et donc comprendre la médisance
comprendre ses motivations ses origines
et en particulier ses origines
psychologiques c'est comprendre sa
signification
philosophique je rappelle que pour
Nietzsche le but de la philosophie c'est
d'être une
généalogie c'est ce que rappelle delus
dans son livre Nietzsche et la
philosophie quand il dit que pour
Nietzsche je cite nous avons toujours
les croyances les sentiments les pensées
que nous méritons en fonction de notre
manière d'être ou de notre style de vie
pratiquer la médisance être animé par le
besoin de dénigrer ce n'est donc pas
seulement un trait de
caractère c'est l'expression d'une
identité
philosophique et donc tout au long de
cet épisode on va s'appuyer sur des
textes de Nietzsche pour proposer un
portrait psychophilosophique du médison
et ainsi montrer en quoi pour Nietzsche
la médisance est la manifestation
pratique de l'identité de celui qu'il
appelle l'homme du
ressentiment alors la médisance on sait
tous à quoi ça correspond mais on va
quand même en donner une définition pour
savoir exactement de quoi on parle la
médisance c'est le besoin plus ou moins
prononcé plus ou moins pathologique de
dire du mal des autres c'est le besoin
de critiquer de rabaisser de calomnier
c'est faire de la malveillance envers
autrui le moteur de toutes ces
conversations la médisance c'est pointer
vers celui qu'on veut accabler un
doigqueœur et c'est en tirer du
plaisir pourquoi du plaisir parce qu'à
travers la médisance le faible a
l'impression de prendre sa revanche sur
le
fort de prendre sa revanche et par la
même occasion de prendre sa place
d'inverser les rôles et c'est pour ça
que je vous ai parlé de la morale juste
avant de la morale
d'esclave parce que ce que montre
Nietzsche c'est que la médisance et la
morale obéissent exactement au même
mécanisme à savoir
l'inversion la morale c'est l'inversion
des valeurs on remplace l'exaltation de
la vie par la haine de la vie la
médisance c'est l'inversion des rôles la
victime devient bourreau et le bourreau
devient victime dans les deux cas c'est
une vengeance dans les deux cas c'est un
produit du
ressentiment je vais vous proposer une
formule qui résume ce que nous dit
Nietzsche à propos de la médisance la
médisance c'est la forme
désinhibée de ce dont la morale et la
forme
inhibée ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que la morale est une inversion des
rôles entre le faible et le fort sous
couvert de justice on punit le fort
parce que du point de vue de la morale
d'esclave la force c'est le
mal donc le besoin de punir le fort le
besoin de se venger du fort n'est pas
directement
assumé il passe par le fil des valeurs
morales alors que la médisance c'est une
inversion des rôles entre le faible et
le fort pour le seul plaisir de dire du
mal alors certes le médisant assume
rarement sa médisance il assume rarement
de dire du mal pour le seul plaisir de
dire du mal il trouve toujours des
justifications rationnelles à sa
médisance ce que nietzch appelle des
faux fuyants et ce faisant il se cache à
lui-même sa médisant
il se cache à lui-même son
ressentiment mais ce qu'il ne peut pas
se cacher c'est le plaisir qu'il éprouve
à dire du mal c'est le plaisir qu'il
éprouve à rabaisser les autres ce que
dit Nietzsche c'est qu'on a beau se
réfugier derrière toutes les
justifications qu'on veut derrière
l'objectivité derrière la vérité
derrière la sincérité ce qu'on recherche
à travers la médisance c'est la
vengeance Nietzsche résume ça dans une
phrase je cite personne n'accuse sans
avoir l'arrièrepensée de la punition et
de la
vengeance donc la médisance comme la
morale exprime un désir de vengeance
mais sauf qu'il y a un problème ce
problème c'est que c'est une vengeance
dans laquelle le faible continue
d'exprimer sa faiblesse puisque
précisément dire du mal c'est exprimer
quelque chose qui est qui est en nous je
rappelle que pour Nietzsche on a les
valeurs de sa psychologie et on a la
psychologie de sa
physiologie le faible a une psychologie
de faible qui découle de sa physiologie
de faible et sa psychologie de faible se
prolonge dans une morale de
faible morale de faible dont le but
inassumé est de se venger du fort la
médisance c'est donc le besoin
d'expulser hors de soi de transférer à
l'extérieur de soi quelque chose qui
fondamentalement est en
soi alors soyons précis Nietzsche fait
la distinction entre deux formes de
vengeance ce qu'il appelle la vengeance
de conservation et la vengeance de
compensation la vengeance de
conservation c'est quand la vengeance a
pour but d'éviter un dommage futur on se
venge d'un ennemi qui nous a attaqué
pour le dissuader de de nous
réattaquer la vengeance de compensation
c'est quand la vengeance ne sert pas à
éviter une nouvelle attaque quand le mal
est pour ainsi dire déjà fait et que du
coup on cherche juste à se soulager
parce qu'on s'est senti humilié et qu'on
veut que celui qui nous a humilié
partage notre humiliation qu'il partage
notre
souffrance donc quand il critique le
médisant extériorise sa souffrance
mais en même temps qu'il extériorise sa
souffrance il exprime son besoin de
l'extérioriser donc il exprime la
souffrance qui est à l'origine de son
besoin
d'extériorisation pas besoin d'avoir un
de en psychologie pour comprendre que
celui qui ne peut pas s'empêcher de
critiquer qui établit son rapport à
l'autre sur le mode quasi exclusif de la
malveillance et de l'insulte est en proi
à une frustration à un mal
et un besoin de reporter son mal-être
sur les autres dire du mal pour oublier
son propre
mal et donc c'est en cela que le
médisant se ment à lui-même quand il
croit prendre la place du fort parce
qu'on prend pas la place du fort en
criant je souffre on prend pas la place
du fort en dirigeant vers Lui notre
ressentiment on prend la place du fort
en sortant du ressentiment
je vais le dire autrement le fort ce
n'est pas celui qui libère son
ressentiment c'est celui qui se libère
du
ressentiment on l'a dit le ressentiment
c'est la haine de la vie parce que la
vie est un affrontement de force et que
dans cet affrontement de force le faible
est en danger donc la haine du faible
trouve son origine dans la peur la peur
d'être confronté au fort et cette peur
génère chez le faible un sentiment de
honte le faible a honte de sa faiblesse
et Nietzsche nous dit que c'est pour ça
que quand le faible cherche à se venger
du fort la méthode qu'il utilise c'est
la
punition parce que le principe de la
punition c'est de donner honte c'est
d'humilier et comme le faible est
sensible à la honte comme il est
sensible
l'humiliation il veut transférer sa
propre humiliation sur le
fort lui faire subir ce qu'il subit ou
ce qu' l' a subi donc on a bien à faaire
à ce qu'on appelle en psychologie un
mécanisme de
projection c'est-à-dire de déplacement à
l'extérieur de soi d'une réalité
intérieure donc le point de départ de la
médisance c'est un sentiment
d'infériorité sentiment d'infériorit é
paradoxale d'ailleurs parce qu'il se
nourrit de l'idée que c'est celui qu'on
critique qui est inférieur il se nourrit
de l'idée que nous sommes supérieurs à
celui que nous critiquons bah oui
puisque précisément la médisance est un
mécanisme
d'inversion je vais prendre un exemple
qui parlera à tout le monde quand on est
jaloux de quelqu'un qu'est-ce qu'on fait
on le critique on le dénigre on le
rabaisse on dit pas cette personne est
géniale puisque ce qu'on veut c'est
qu'on dise que c'est nous qui sommes
géniaux donc quand quelqu'un a du succès
auprès des autres et que nous sommes
envieux de ce succès quand on pense que
ce succès devrait normalement nous
revenir à nous on rationalise notre
jalousie et on trouve tous les défauts
possible chez la personne pour se
convaincre qu'elle ne mérite pas son
succès sans se rendre compte qu'en
faisant ça on ne fait que confirmer
notre sentiment
d'infériorité quand on n'est pas jaloux
et que quelqu'un a du succès auprès des
autres on n'éprouve pas le besoin de le
dénigrer parce que croire qu'on va
annuler le succès de quelqu'un en
faisant l'étalage de notre ressentiment
c'est très naïf et surtout c'est
occulter les raisons profondes pour
lesquelles on la critique les raisons
véritables quand on se sent obligé de
débiner la personne quand on se sent
obligé de faire un exposé sur ses
défauts pour montrer à quel point son
succès n'est pas justifié c'est qu'on le
vit mal c'est qu'on est touché par le
fait qu'elle estit du succès et qu'on
voudrait que ça s'arrête quoi qu'on dise
pour rationaliser notre
réaction je vais vous lire une citation
de Nietzsche qu'on trouve dans humain
trop humain et dans laquelle nie met en
relation la médisance et le sentiment
d'infériorité je cite il ne sont pas
rares c'est peut-être même la majorité
les hommes qui ont absolument besoin
pour maintenir leur estime de même de
rabaisser et de dénigrer dans la
représentation qu'ils s'en font tous les
hommes qu'ils
connaissent donc là que nous dit
Nietzsche il nous dit que le besoin de
rabaisser a pour but le maintien de l'ES
de soi donc ça c'est ce qu'on a expliqué
tout à l'heure à savoir que dans un
rapport d'inégalité dans un rapport
hiérarchique en l'occurrence dans un
rapport hiérarchique entre le fort et le
faible si le faible est dans
l'incapacité de s'élever au niveau du
fort sa seule solution c'est d'abaisser
le fort à son niveau en le dénigrant en
le salissant d'ailleurs étymologiquement
dénigrer ça veut dire rendre noir
dénigrer c'est
obscurcir le médisant évolue dans la
noirceur et ça c'est fondamental parce
que cette noirceur dans laquelle il
évolue le médisant veut l'étendre à tous
ceux qui n'y évoluent pas c'est pour ça
qu'il cherche à tout
médiocriser parce que s'il arrive à se
convaincre que tout le monde est
médiocre sa propre médiocrité devient
supportable c'est comme si elle
s'annulait alors qu'à l'inverse à chaque
fois qu'un homme s'élève au-dessus de la
médiocrité c'est un rappel que lui n'y
est pas parvenu donc que fait celui qui
n'est pas parvenu à s'élever et qui
parce qu'il n'y est pas parvenu ne veut
pas que les autres puissent s'élever il
les rabaisse il les rabaisse par les
mots à défaut de pouvoir les rabaisser
par les
actes donc à chaque fois que vous
entendez quelqu'un m dire dites-vous
bien qu'il ne ne le fait pas par plaisir
il le fait par
besoin le besoin de se persuader que les
autres sont médiocres car si les autres
sont médiocres c'est moins honteux de
l'être
soi-même le médisant est sensible à la
honte de manière générale il est
sensible à tout ce à quoi le fort est
indifférent exemple la réputation le
médisan est très sensible à la
réputation c'est d'ailleurs parce qu'il
est sensible à la réputation qu'il s'en
prend à la réputation des autres et il y
est d'autant plus sensible qu'il prétend
ne pas
l'être puisque le reconnaître ce serait
reconnaître sa faiblesse ce
qu'évidemment il ne veut pas le médisant
est sensible à la validation sociale
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que le médisant
exerce toujours sa médisance à
l'intérieur de son groupe quand vous
pensez à la médisance l'image que ça
évoque en vous ce n'est pas quelqu'un
qui critique les autres tout seul dans
son coin c'est plutôt le groupe de
médisans les Comè le médisant a besoin
du groupe parce que le groupe lui donne
l'impression d'avoir une importance et
donc de s'élever par la
médisance le médisant c'est celui à qui
on demande de dénigrer pour nous
divertir donc il y a un écosystème de la
médisance
un écosystème au sein duquel le médisant
peut jouir d'une certaine autorité voire
d'une certaine aura et le médisant a
aussi besoin du groupe pour lui faire
oublier que s'il dénigre c'est par
ressentiment on oublie que la médisance
est un produit du ressentiment en en
faisant un jeu un jeu collectif c'est
pour ça que les médisant aiment se
rassembler pour
critiquer parce que c'est un moyen pour
eux de Sauto persuadé qu'ils ne sont pas
aigris ou envieux mais qu'ils sont
supérieurs un groupe dans lequel tout le
monde partage notre ressentiment est un
groupe qui fait oublier qu'il est bâti
sur le ressentiment puisqu'il le
normalise par définition on ne constate
pas ce qui est normal on constate ce qui
sort de la norme quand la médisance est
normalisée dans un groupe on ne voit
même plus que c'est la médisance qui
nous relie l'effet de groupe dissou le
discernement c'est le propre de tous les
phénomènes collectifs de nous ôter notre
individualité il y a un très bon roman
de jantelé qui s'appelle mangez-le si
vous voulez basé sur une histoire vraie
qui décrit le lynchage d'un homme dans
un village de Dordogne en
1870 la France vient d'entrer en guerre
contre la Prusse Alam monis est un
aristocrate de 32S an il participe à la
foire du village de
hautefille et là des villageois
commencent à le molester parce que son
cousin aurait été entendu le matin en
train de crier vive la
République sans qu'il puisse rien faire
pour se soustraire au groupe monis est
tabassé torturé et
brûlé et c'est là que le maire du
village aurait dit aux habitants
mangez-le si vous voulez qui a été
démenti lors du procès bon et bien cette
affaire elle est représentative de la
mécanique psychologique des phénomèn de
groupe phénomène de groupe qui rend
possible la dilution de la
responsabilité j'ai fait ça parce que
tout le monde faisait ça je n'ai fait
que suivre le mouvement et bien suivre
le mouvement c'est exactement ça pour
Nietzsche qui caractérise l'homme du
ressentiment dans dans le gay savoir
Nietzsche parle lui-même des hommes de
troupeau et de l'instinct de troupeau un
homme de troupeau c'est quelqu'un qui
s'épanouit dans le conformisme du
groupe donc il y a deux raisons pour
lesquelles la médisance va de paire avec
les phénomènes de groupe la première
raison c'est que la médisance repose sur
l'existence d'une cible commune de ce
que René gerérard appelait un bou
émissaire la médisance c'est la
désignation d'une victime qu'on accable
de tous les mots une victime
expiatoire je rappelle que le Bou
émissaire à l'origine c'était une
coutume biblique qui voulait qu'on
charge un bou de tous les péchés de la
communauté et qu'on le chasse dans le
désert pour qu'il les éloigne de la cité
donc ça s'inscrit dans une logique
sacrificielle on sacrifie le bouc
émissaire pour souder la commun noté et
pour la
revivifier bien c'est exactement cette
mécanique qui est à l'œuvre dans la
médisance le Bou émissaire c'est celui
contre lequel se coalisent les
médisants contre lequel se coalisent
leurs
ressentiments leur frustration leur
amertume donc ça c'est la première
raison la deuxième raison c'est que
Nietzsche explique dans la généalogie de
la morale que la morale d'esclave est le
produit de la coalition des faibles
contre les forts des hommes du
ressentiment contre les hommes
supérieurs alors je précise quand même
parce qu'évidemment hommes supérieurs ça
peut donner lieu à des interprétations
douteuse l'homme supérieur chez
Nietzsche c'est l'homme affranchi
affranchi de quoi bah du ressentiment
justement et de tout ce qui découle du
ressentiment l'homme supérieur c'est
l'homme qui n'est soumis à aucun système
de valeur parce qu'il est le créateur de
son propre système de
valeur c'est celui qui crée les valeurs
qu'il suit et qui suit les valeurs qu'il
crée on va reparler dans un instant donc
le surhomme c'est l'homme supérieur au
sens littéral de supérieur c'est-à-dire
qui est au-dessus au-dessus du
troupeau la morale du surhomme Nietzsche
l'appelle la morale
aristocratique aristocratique aristos en
grec ça veut dire les meilleurs meilleur
au sens de plus
accompli donc la morale aristocratique
ne se réduit pas à la morale de la
classe
aristocratique même si historiquement ce
sont les membres de l'aristocratie qui
incarnaient les valeurs du
surhomme les valeurs
d'impétuosité
d'exaltation de dépassement de de
soi c'est ça la morale aristocratique la
morale du dépassement et ce n'est pas
pour rien si les titres de noblesse
incluent des références à la
supériorité quand on dit Votre Altesse
l'altesse c'est la hauteur comme dans
altitude c'est l'idée d'élévation et
donc ce que nous dit Nietzsche dans la
généalogie de la morale c'est qu'avant
que nos valeurs morales ne soient
instituées et généralisé
nos valeurs morales c'est-à-dire nos
valeurs traditionnelles la pitié la
vulnérabilité
l'altruisme toutes ces valeurs qui pour
Nietzsche sont des émanations de la
faiblesse puisque ce sont les faibles
qui ont besoin d'elle pour pouvoir
survivre avant l'instauration de ces
valeurs donc il y avait les valeurs
aristocratiques ce que Nietzsche appelle
la morale des maîtres pour la distinguer
de la morale d'esclave
et donc j'ai commencé à le dire tout à
l'heure la morale du surhomme c'est la
morale de
l'affirmation de l'affirmation de soi et
de la vie c'est la morale qui dit oui à
la
vie alors que la morale d'esclave c'est
une morale qui dit non à la vie et qui
fait de ce n le socle de ses
valeurs si la morale du surhomme est une
morale de l'affirmation la morale
d'esclave est une morale de la négation
et plus précisément encore une morale de
la
réaction je vais vous lire un passage de
généalogie de la morale dans lequel
Nietzsche résume tout ça je cite le
soulèvement des esclaves dans la morale
commence lorsque le ressentiment devient
lui-même créateur et engendre des
valeurs le ressentiment de ces êtres
àquis la réaction vér itable celle de
l'action est interdite et que seul une
vengeance imaginaire peut indemniser
alors que toute morale aristocratique nî
d'un oui triomphant adressé à soi-même
de primabord la morale des esclaves dit
non à un dehors à un autre à un
différent de soi-même et ce nom est son
acte créateur cette inversion du regard
posant les valeurs la nécessité qui
pousse à se tourner vers le dehors
plutôt que vers soi-même
cela relève justement du ressentiment la
morale des esclaves a toujours et avant
tout besoin pour prendre naissance d'un
monde hostile et extérieur elle a
physiologiquement parlant besoin
d'excitation extérieure pour agir son
action est foncièrement une
réaction alors là c'est très éclairant
c'est très éclairant parce que niets
montre ici que les deux morales qui sont
en opposition la morale affirmative du
surhomme et la morale négative de
l'esclave ces deux morales sont le
prolongement de deux modes d'existence
il faudrait dire de deux forces une
force proactive et une force
réactive la force proactive c'est celle
qui aboutit à la création tandis que la
force réactive est celle qui aboutit à
la
contradiction le surhomme évolue dans
l'action il évolue dans l'affirmation de
lui-même et de ses propres valeurs
concrètement ça signifie que
l'anthropologie du surhomme c'est
l'indifférence le surhomme est
indifférent à ce que les gens font il
est indifférent à ce que les gens
pensent il ne surveille pas les
comportements pour savoir si ça c'est
bien ou ça c'est mal il se contente
d'incarner sa volonté de puissance donc
le surhomme ne vit pas vous l'aurez
compris dans le besoin obsessionnel
d'écraser ou d'humilier les autres
précisément parce qu'il s'en fiche des
autres il a pas le temps il est tourné
vers lui-même et vers la vie à l'inverse
l'homme du ressentiment est tourné vers
les autres il fait dépendre son mode
d'être de ce que font les autres ou de
ce que disent les autres en clair
l'anthropologie de l'homme du
ressentiment c'est la réaction il n'agit
pas il réagit et réagir ça veut dire
agir
contre donc l'homme du ressentiment est
totalement dépendant de ce que font les
autres il a besoin des autres pour
pouvoir exister par rapport à eux
évidemment vous voyez en quoi ça
s'applique parfaitement à la médisance
puisque la médisance c'est le besoin de
réagir à ce que font les autres
mais il faut ajouter un élément à savoir
que comme on l'a vu l'homme du
ressentiment n'est pas seulement dans la
réaction il est aussi dans la négation
et c'est pour ça que nietz utilise le
mot
ressentiment le ressentiment c'est le
sentiment contre l'homme du ressentiment
est toujours contre et quand il est pour
il est pour ce qui est contre il est
pour interdire pour condamner pour
empêcher il est pour dénoncer ou pour
porter plainte il est pour la
négation ça ne vous rappelle rien
comment le médisant occupe-t-il son
temps il occupe son temps à être
contre puisque la critique est son
moteur le médisant ne s'affirme qu'en
niant il ne rit pas il
ricane rire c'est cré
ricaner c'est
réagir rire c'est dire oui à la vie
ricaner c'est se venger de la
vie tous les registres du ressentiment
sont dans son
répertoire
l'ironie le sarcasme la
causticité il ne peut rire qu'en se
moquant c'est-à-dire en riant
de car son plaisir se situe dans la
diminution Nietzsche parle de ça dans
humain trop humain il appelle ça la joie
maligne shadon Freud en allemand la joie
maligne c'est la joie qui se réjouit du
mal la joie du pauvre je cite la joie
maligne que l'on éprouve en face du mal
d'autrui provient du fait que chacun se
sent mal en point sous bien des rapports
qu'il a lui aussi ses soucis ses remords
ses douleurs et qu'il ne les ignore pas
le dommage qui touche l'autre fait de
lui son égal il réconcilie sa jalousie
s'il a des raisons momentanées pour être
heureux lui-même il n'en accumule pas
moins les malheurs du prochain comme un
capital dans sa mémoire pour le faire
valoir dès que sur lui aussi le malheur
se met à fondre c'est là également une
façon d'avoir une joie maligne le
sentiment de l'égalité veut donc
appliquer sa mesure au domaine du
bonheur et du hasard la joie maligne est
l'expression la plus vulgaire par quoi
se manifeste la victoire et le
rétablissement de
l'égalité vous vous souvenez de ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure à propos de
l'égalité la médisance c'est un moyen
pour le faible de rabaisser le fort à
son niveau et ainsi de se donner
l'illusion d'une égalité ce que
Nietzsche ajoute ici c'est que l'homme
du ressentiment se réjouit du malheur de
son prochain parce qu'il y trouve un
rappel de son propre
malheur de ses propres défaillances en
clair il se sent moins seul et le fait
que l'homme du ressentiment se réjouisse
et se nourrisse du malheur des autres ça
permet d'écarter l'idée selon laquelle
la médisance ne serait en réalité pas de
la médisance mais qu'elle serait juste
une critique
objective vous savez les gens qui
dénigrent et qui disent
je ne critique pas je
constate mais si la médisance n'était
que du constat si elle n'était pas de la
médisance c'est-à-dire une expression du
ressentiment mais une critique
objective dans le but de corriger dans
le but
d'améliorer comment se fait-il que le
médisant n'applique jamais la critique à
lui-même si la critique est nécessaire
utile
saine pourquoi ne pas encourager les
autres à nous critiquer également car
vous remarquerez que si l'homme du
ressentiment est très pront à critiquer
les autres il est allergique à sa propre
critique ce qui prouve bien que quand le
médisant critique l'objectivité n'est
qu'un masque
elle n'est qu'un
mensonge un mensonge sur sa motivation
profonde qui n'est pas un désir
d'élévation mais un désir de
vengeance pour l'homme du ressentiment
la critique est une arme et on dirige
pas une arme contre
soi au 19e siècle il y avait un critique
littéraire français assez connu qui
s'appelait sainte bu et saintebuv
adressait des critiques extrêmement
virulentes à des écrivains que tout le
monde s'accordait à reconnaître comme de
grands écrivains par exemple Balzac ou
par exemple
standandal évidemment nul écrivain n'est
à l'abri de la critique mais ce qui
était reproché à saintbuv et notamment
ce que Nietzsche reprochait à saintbuv
c'était de ne pas réussir à dissimuler
son aigreur à l'égard des auteurs qu'il
critiquaient c'était de laisser
transparaître dans ses critiques une
amertume et un désir de
vengeance c'était de confondre critique
et
médisance voilà ce qu'écrit niet cédant
le crépuscule des idoles je cite sainbv
est plein de petites hainees contre tous
les esprits viriles il a ça et là
raffiné curieux ennuyé aux écoutes un
être féminin au fond avec des vengeances
de femmes et des Sensualités de femmes
en tant que psychologue un génie de
médisance inépuisable dans les moyens de
de placer cette médisance personne ne
s'entend aussi bien à mêler du poison à
l'éloge ses instincts inférieurs sont
plébéens et parents au ressentiments de
Rousseau donc il est romantique car sous
tout le romantisme grimace et guettete
l'instinct de vengeance de Rousseau
révolutionnaire mais passablement
contenu par la crainte sans indépendance
devant tout ce qui possède de la force
l'opinion publique l'Académie la cour
sans excepter Port Royal irrité contre
tout ce que les hommes et les choses ont
de grand contre tout ce qui croit en
soi-même suffisamment poète et
demi-femme pour sentir encore la
puissance de ce qui est grand sans cesse
recoquillé comme ce verre célèbre parce
qu'il sent toujours qu'on lui marche
dessus dans ce texte Nietzsche nous
donne une dernière information à propos
de la médisance une information qui
synthétise tout ce qu'on a on a dit
jusqu'à présent à savoir quelle est
l'expression d'un sentiment
d'impuissance le médisant se sent
impuissant impuissant à quoi impuissant
à créer
impuissant à produire une œuvre à être
reconnu pour ses
réalisations le grand écrivain a quelque
chose du surhomme il crée un monde un
monde avec ses propres règles ses
propres lois ses propres
valeurs le critique littéraire lui est
condamné à réagir à placer ses pas dans
ceux de celui qu'il
critique voilà pourquoi sa seule option
s'il veut se distinguer c'est de jeter
le discrédit sur l'œuvre qu'il critique
à moins qu'il ne décide de créer sa
propre œuvre mais ça ça demande
davantage que du sarcasme
ça demande du travail de l'audace de la
résistance aux critiques ça demande de
la volonté
nietzsécrit je cite les hommes doués
mais non Chalons auront toujours l'air
un peu irrité lorsque l'un de leurs amis
aura terminé un bon travail leur
jalousie s'éveille ils ont honte de leur
paresse ou plutôt ils craignent que
l'homme actif ne les méprise alors en
encore plus que d'ordinaire c'est dans
cette disposition d'esprit qu'il
critiquent l'œuvre nouvelle et leur
critique devient de la
vengeance vous l'ignorez peut-être mais
le concept de ressentiment chez
Nietzsche a ouvert le champ à de
nombreuses études en psychologie des
études qui semblent donner raison à
Nietzsche puisqu'elle mettent en
évidence la relation entre médisance et
vulnérabilité
entre besoin de critiquer et sentiment
d'insécurité dans ces études voilà ce
qu'on peut lire je cite les personnes
les plus critiques se comparent
continuellement aux autres elles envent
la chance des autres mais elles
nourrissent aussi l'idée narcissique
qu'ell mérite mieux que les autres parce
qu'elle se croi supérieur ce sont des
personnes à faible estime de soi avec
une tendance à l'appréhension et des
difficultés à communiquer de manière
assertive leurs besoins émotionnels
elles ont donc recours à la critique et
au drame pour atteindre leurs objectifs
la propension à critiquer les autres
répond à une profonde peur d'être jugé
bien que les personnes qui critiquent
les autres puissent être très singlantes
à la base de leur attitude se trouve une
grande fragilité émotionnelle un ego
hyper réactif et extrêmement sensible
qui cherche à s'apaiser par la critique
négative tous ces éléments confirment
une chose à savoir que si la médisance
est effectivement l'arme des
impuissants il s'agit moins d'une arme
d'agression qu'une arme de
défense ce que veut le médisant ce n'est
pas tant faire du mal aux autre que se
faire du bien à lui ce n'est pas tant
rabaisser l'autre que
s'élever donc la prochaine fois que vous
croiserez la route d'un médison
gardez à l'esprit cette citation de
Nietzsche les insectes piquent non par
méchanceté mais parce que eux aussi
veulent vivre il en est de même des
critiques ils veulent notre sang et non
pas notre douleur je vous
[Musique]
remerci